Queridos amigos, si echamos un vistazo al mapa
del mundo y lo analizamos con detalle, nos daremos
cuenta de que hay fronteras muy particulares.
La de España con Marruecos a través de las
ciudades de Ceuta y Melilla, por ejemplo,
es una que llama mucho la atención. La de
Israel con Gaza y Cisjordania también es una
de las más particulares – que os voy a contar.
Pero, os hago una pregunta, ¿conocéis
alguna isla con alguna frontera extraña?
¿Conocéis el caso de alguna isla partida
por la mitad y en la que las dos mitades,
digamos por ser educados, no se soporten mucho?
Pues sí, esas islas y esas fronteras existen.
Quizás muchos estéis pensando en la frontera que
separa a Brunéi de Indonesia o en la que parte
por la mitad la isla de Chipre o la de Irlanda.
Sin embargo, en esta ocasión no vamos a viajar
hasta el sudeste asiático ni tampoco nos vamos
a quedar en Europa. Hoy encontraremos a nuestros
protagonistas en pleno mar caribe.
Porque, sí, en el caribe hay otra
isla que también acoge a dos países.
¿Sabríais decirme cuál es? 3,2,1…
¡Premio! Efectivamente, hablamos
de la isla de la española.